[Music]
okay
hi everyone i hope you can hear me uh
thank you all for joining us today
my name is jeffy goldwasser i'm the
director of the science institute
for theory of computing and
for all of you who don't know it it's an
international venue for collaborative
research in theoretical computer science
is reaching out also to the sciences in
other fields of computer science
we were established in 2012 with a
generous grant from the simons
foundation
um and we come together
here at senior scientists junior
scientists the future generation to
do research and discuss topic of
interest and today it's
really my great pleasure to introduce a
very distinguished panel and an event
um it's part of our theoretically
speaking public
lecture series we are going to be
talking about the movie coded bias
which premiered in 2002 uh sunday's film
festival 2020 sorry
so it's very recent and the film um
uh perhaps many of you have seen it
those who haven't it's streaming on
netflix right now and i highly recommend
it my guess is that
after this panel you definitely will go
and see it if you haven't seen it yet
now what the film does it explores the
impact of machine learning algorithms
on all parts of our life and society on
systematic issues of algorithmic bias
and the
impact it can have on our lives today
and in the future
and uh i'm extremely fortunate that
we're going to have this panel to
discuss it a
simon's institute has been active in
this area to
the extent um uh to some extent so far
we have um had several clusters on
algorithmic fairness and some of you
have been part of them
in previous summers and this is also
part of a larger initiative
on algorithms society and the law and
some of you have been also in a previous
workshop that we had assignments on
wrong at the root
a few years ago so i'm delighted to host
this panel
i'm really delighted that you all agreed
to come and join us and especially
i'd like to introduce our um going to be
fearless leader
aisha wilson who's going to moderate the
palin panel and nisha is a
an assistant professor of elective
engineering and computer science at mit
and she's a member of the faculty of the
ai and decision making
part of computer science and she has a
ba from harvard
and a phd from berkeley in statistics so
i'm
especially um even more happy to host
you in berkeley again
even if it's virtual and her research
focuses on things very related to the
theme of this panel
logical uh foundations and theory of
various topics in machine learning
so please welcome asia and i'm going to
give you the floor thank you so much
thank you so much shafi for that
wonderful introduction
i'm really excited to have such a great
panel here
um i guess we'll start by
discussing a little bit with shalini
kentaya the director who is here
about the film and then we'll bring in
our other panelists to
discuss in an open forum our thoughts
and feelings about the film
so um without further ado i'm just going
to introduce yolini so
as shoppy mentioned uh she's the
director of coded bias which debuted at
the sundance film festival in 2020
she also had her debut catching the sun
which premiered at the la film festival
and was named a new york times critics
pick
she's a ted fellow a fulbright scholar
and associate of the uc berkeley
graduate school of journalism so
just super impressive and so happy to
have her here welcome
thank you so much for having me it's an
honor to be here
fantastic yeah i'm just so excited to
ask you questions
um i think one of the first things that
stood out to me
was the diversity of examples in the
film you had
examples of algorithmic bias spanning
education
health care risk assessment tools
i was just wondering about how you came
to these examples
um well thank you again and i'm so
excited to be in conversation with this
astute panel
i um i just want to say that you know
three years ago when i started making
this film i didn't even know what an
algorithm was
i think my street cred in the game is
that i'm a sci-fi fanatic
and everything that i had known about
artificial intelligence had come through
the imagination of
steven spielberg or stanley kubrick i'm
definitely someone who's watched blade
runner way too many times
um and i don't think that my background
as a sci-fi fanatic which i think is how
most of the public understands
artificial intelligence
had really prepared me for the ways in
which
um ai has is being used in the now
and um i stumbled down the rabbit hole
when i read a book called weapons of
math destruction by kathy o'neil
and i was
uh completely kind of shocked
to learn the ways in which
algorithms machine learning ai is
increasingly becoming this gatekeeper of
opportunity oftentimes an invisible
gatekeeper
of opportunity and deciding really
important things like
who gets hired who gets what quality
of health care even how long a prison
sentence someone may serve
and i think at the same time as i was
sort of grappling
with the way in which human beings are
outsourcing
our uh decision making and our autonomy
to machines
in ways that i think change
lives and uh shape human destinies
i came across a talk that joy bellamy
gave
and um
was startled to understand
that these same systems that we are
putting our blind faith in
um to make so many important decisions
have not been vetted for racial bias or
for gender bias
or in many cases
you know more broadly they haven't been
vetted to make sure they won't
hurt people that they won't cause harm
and i was very
shocked to understand that in many cases
they haven't even been vetted for some
shared standard of accuracy
outside of the companies that stand to
benefit economically from their
deployment
and that's when i really begin to
understand
that everything i love and value as a
free person living in a democracy
access to fair and accurate information
uh free and fair elections
the uh fair equal
uh opportunity and employment the fact
that women or lgbtq people or
people of color shouldn't be
discriminated against in the workplace
that communities of color shouldn't have
undue police scrutiny
that all of the things that i value and
hold dear
are rapidly being transformed
by algorithms and by ai and
that's when i really began to understand
quite what joy ballerini articulates so
clearly in the film
which is that we could essentially roll
back 50 years of civil rights advances
in the name of trusting these systems to
be
fair to be unbiased um
and to be just when when in many cases
they're not
yeah you mentioned those impacted i
think
one of the things your film does so
powerfully is actually
center people who are actually impacted
you had
janae uh you had daniel santos the
teacher in houston
and tanya meyer live by sartonia myers
who is
uh affected by a risk assessment tool
how did you find these people who were
impacted
well i'm really grateful i mean i think
that um
coded bias i think that the challenge of
making it was really twofold one was to
disseminate really complex science in a
way that
your grandma understands and your 12
year old understands but also
has some integrity still in the science
and i think when it comes to ai all of
the knowledge has been in the hands of
the few
so all of the power has been in the
hands of the few
so i think part of it was the challenge
of taking someone's phd dissertation
and trying to translate it into two
minutes that somehow was cinematic and
visual
and um and hopefully entertaining in
some way
but i think the other challenge of the
film
was really exactly what you said
which is to put a human face to really
connect the communities that have skin
in the game
that really um have something at stake
with these systems and i think so often
i think eli pariser was tweeting and he
said like
i've been to a lot of conferences on the
history of technology but not on the
the future of humanity the future of
technology but not the future of
humanity and i think so many times that
we talk about
tech we talk about it in a way that
doesn't
certainly doesn't include people but
also
um isn't about
people isn't human-centered and um
one of the challenges i had in making
the film
was just how opaque these systems of
power are
and it's so hard for someone to even
know they've been discriminated against
that there was an
algorithm involved in that system
and for me it was also really important
to
show autonomy and
agency and the fact that everyday people
without degrees from berkeley or mit or
stanford can still fight back
against technological systems and
you know and i've seen that time and
time again i always say that
you know documentaries remind me that
everyday people can make a difference
and i saw that in the stories of daniel
santos who
you know you you could stand ten ten
feet away from this man and know that
what a great teacher he is
and yet an algorithm that was designed
first of all to
to judge fertility and bulls
somehow gets used to judge whether a
teacher is a good teacher i kid you not
that was the origin of that algorithm
and um and then you know
and it's only through that process and
we trust it like big magic
oh he's got a red mark on his record he
is a bad teacher he needs discipline
and we treat it like it is um
uh cathy o'neil says uh it's data
science so we should treat it like a
science we shouldn't trade it treat it
like a faith-based religion
but we're treating it we're putting our
faith in these systems
in this god-like way of saying oh he has
a bad mark and
not looking at the values encoded in
those systems like
can we even have an algorithm that
judges whether a teacher is a good
teacher
uh are we what are we saying here are we
saying like
okay the kids improvement of scores
that's all
that goes into making a good teacher and
a teacher like daniel santos who teaches
kids that aren't privileged
where 80 of those kids are coming in as
english as a second language
and he's being penalized for the kids
being not privileged
and not performing well in this scoring
system and
the way in which that becomes a form of
power that he cannot question
it's a black box and the way that he was
able to fight against it and say
this violated my due process if you fire
me
you have to tell me why if you
discipline me you have to tell me why
and the fact that even the people who
invent these systems don't
totally understand how they work or
arrived at that system
makes this new kind of opaque power that
cannot be questioned
and that's why i'm so heartened by
people like him and like renee moran of
brooklyn
who who didn't even know what biometric
data was
um the third generation brooklynite um
um living in that building yeah the
landlord says
you have to opt out not even we need
your consent but
you have to opt out we're going to put
this in a a
a building which is already high
surveillance
and um not only did trine moran
and i see me downs educate their their
community
and their neighbors and keep their
landlord from installing this kind of
racially biased invasive surveillance
technology in the place they live
but they inspired the first legislation
in the state of new york
that would inspire other um residents to
do
uh that would that would prevent other
residents from having to deal with that
same kind of surveillance
and to me that is the power of literacy
and um it's my hope that coded bias
um you know pulls up a chair for all of
us
and says we all have a place at the
table
because these technologies are deployed
on all of us
in how these technologies are are
designed
and deployed and really in the fight for
more ethical and less biased
technologies that define our future yeah
that's such an important point about how
so much can be lost
when you move to make it measurable and
how that can impact people
that's great um another thing along the
lines of directorial choices the last
kind of question along these lines is um
you know while joy was a common thread
throughout the film
your film centered a lot of voices we
had a lot of lawyers authors
civil rights attorneys a variety of
women and people of color who are in the
tech space
and i think even an apartheid historian
um
and i think what was noticeably absent
was
there weren't gatekeepers who were
featured or
or people who weren't necessarily hands
on
developing the algorithm so i just
wanted to understand
which i loved i just wanted to uh get a
sense for how
what perspectives you chose to include
and why uh
well i'm so grateful i just want to say
i thank you for noticing that i think
that
um this is the beauty and joy of making
a truly independent film with a bold
artistic
voice because uh i don't think coded
bias could have been made in a
commercial framework
i think that it would have called for me
to have those gatekeepers
in the film and i think um
as far as centering voices of people of
color and women
um i think we look at technology films
that have the exact same gender ratios
but they're all mostly predominantly men
and we don't even bat an eyelash we're
so used to
um seeing men talk about the
technologies and mostly white men talk
about the technologies that will define
the future
and honestly um i didn't set out to tell
a film that was predominantly women and
people of color
although i am someone who thinks very uh
conscientiously about whose voices i'm
amplifying
um and representing i do think a lot
about representation
but it was actually the research
that kept bringing me back to these
voices
and um i remember sitting in the edit
room one day and being like wow
it's all women how did that happen does
that mean it's a woman's film i decided
no it's not a woman's film it's just a
film
and um and what i came to realize is
that i feel that code bias is actually
representative of the demographic
that has been fighting um against bias
and for greater ethics in artificial
intelligence
for 20 years and
what is common i think to the cast of
the film
is not only are they um some of the
smartest human beings that i've ever
uh interviewed uh advanced degrees in
data science and
um and and mathematics from from mit
uh and and harvard and every astute
elite institution in the country but
they also had an experience of being
marginalized they also had an identity
that was marginalized
uh they were women they were people of
color they were lgbtq
they were religious minorities and i
think
that misfits of all sorts and i think
that having an experience that was
marginalized
um allowed them to bring more of their
humanity into the room
and shine a light into
some of the blind spots that silicon
valley
may have missed and um
i think that that is a powerful
thing i mean when i when i consider for
the fact that three black women graduate
students
uh joy balawini dr tim nick gabriel and
deborah raji
found racial bias in
commercially available
facial recognition technology that was
already being sold to the fbi
already being sold to ice already being
sold to law enforcement
and somehow that microsoft ibm and
amazon missed
i think that's a rally cry for
more voices at the table and i think
one of the things that i have become
compassionate for is our own predicament
as human beings
and that bias is not something that's in
white men and it's not in a few bad law
enforcement officers
but that bias is an innate human
condition that we all have
and in many times is unconscious to us
and that means that we have to be
hyper vigilant perpetually vigilant
about
um controlling for ai
in the systems that we're designing and
i think that means that building
inclusive teams
is not just good for the pictures or
good for the
communities that have been historically
discriminated against
but actually absolutely essential
in making innovative technologies that
are deployed on the world
and um i think that that
is really important the last thing i
just want to say is
i think that our mat we've had sort of a
stunning lack of imagination
about how these technologies have been
used
and can be used because we've had such a
homogeneous
uh elite group of people um in the rooms
where the design is happening and
it's my hope that coded bias sort of
centers
a new you know a new group of voices and
um somehow unleashes a new kind of
imagination
around how we can use these technologies
in the future yeah i definitely think
your film is definitely a stepping stone
to getting there so i appreciate
appreciate that
your film starts with an example of of
error accuracy problems but then it
definitely weaves in
issues of greater issues of power
governance and accountability
surveillance
and and i would say interleaves between
these topics throughout the movie
through examples and
just people kind of speaking truth to
power and i was just wondering how you
what was your decision process for how
to lay out these various topics and
concerns with ai
well i i i call it the dark night of the
soul
in a documentary because it's sort of
you have to kind of go down the rabbit
hole and
i often joke like there were parties
happening because it was pre-coded when
i made the film and
i was too afraid to go to parties
because i was scared someone would ask
me what i was working on and i couldn't
describe it
i feel like i'm making film about racist
robots that was actually the working
title of the film
and um it was really
as someone who doesn't have a background
in data science or artificial
intelligence it was
incredibly um
i was very humbled and incredibly
uh overwhelmed i would say with what i
was discovering because it was such a
steep learning curve for me
and um it took a long time
just to digest the science communication
and if it's clearly laid out in the film
it was through a lot of long late nights
trying to figure out does this make
sense
if i cut away is that making sense and
then
you know a testing process and i think
the two things were
putting the ideas and then connecting
you to the stakes of why it matters
because i think the beauty of a film
versus a paper a sighted paper of some
sort
is the emotional story is and i
my my the reason i am a filmmaker
is um i think filmmaking is an
engagement
is an extension of my engagement with
the world and
um it is my belief
that we don't act not because we don't
there's actually a wrecked quote quote
we're told breck says
we don't act not because we don't know
what lies beyond the prison gate the
factory wall
we do not act because we don't feel and
i think that when we speak about these
technologies they're often talked about
in a way
that lacks humanity that lacks feeling
that lacks emotion
and one of the things uh the film really
seeks to do
is create empathy for the people who
could be harmed
by these technologies and it's my
sort of theory of change that
the thing that actually machines don't
have um
empathy is actually that that that seed
that sparks social change
and and and and uh roger ebert called
films empathy machines
and so to me um you know the the
structure of the film is very much
um surrounded in sort of the arc of it
is
is the human stories is the narratives
and the human stakes
and that's how i tried to frame the film
really it comes through
actually one of the wrapping up
questions i wanted to ask was the ending
of the film
was i thought remarkably powerful and it
featured an example given by zenith
tofeki
about uh dominic petrov and his decision
to not launch a missile and i think that
the
kind of wrapping message is so that you
know an ai system being fully efficient
is not the most human i think is the
quote that she gave which
you know was very powerful and then your
film ends with
kind of cataloging progress in terms of
regulation
and so i just wanted to ask about that
choice and on a note of on these notes
of regulation
and the human component well
i think that you know i struggled with
whether it
to include that because it almost feels
like an epilogue to joy's art
of the film but i love that story
um and i think we we created we were
very creative about how we created the
soviet union
in that era um
and i think that why that was so
important
was what how much can be at stake
uh when you have the life and death
literally of an
entire nation at the
the whim of a system that doesn't
have morals doesn't have ethics doesn't
have compassion
doesn't have empathy and yet somehow we
call these systems intelligent
that seems like a failed um sort of
vocabulary failure there that you call
something intelligent that doesn't have
empathy or morals or ethics and um
and and so to me that last moment
is kind of the the stakes
of the entire film that this is life and
death and
and in the making of the film i really
saw
everything uh livelihood uh
civil rights uh our people's freedoms
being um governed by these technological
systems
and so to me it was it was this last
button of this is
what's at stakes and then the the other
thing was sort of the voice of the ai
which is throughout the film beginning
in the film and
it was a tricky kind of thing because
actually the first half of it
is actually documentary transcript from
this
chat bot and um i had to beat do a
bleeped version for high school students
and um i i joke that all of the the bat
the foul language is from the chat bot
and um and and so you know you see this
tay
chatbot that goes bad and then there's a
moment where it sort of morphs into the
more
siri uh woman's voice of the actor
and that's narration that i wrote and
that
is sort of this hypothetical this is who
i'm becoming
and ending the film with you know this
question of what form
i will be and leaving that up to kind of
governance
and to me it really was this question of
you know perpetually um it was this
question of the form it will take and
that
being really about our governance and
and to me
it's it's my real belief that you know
i'm so grateful to be having
conversations like this one
because this moment feels very pivotal
to me and i feel that we really have a
moonshot moment where the cement is
still wet
and we can sort of uh let our voices be
heard
and and shape this technology with our
democratic values
and and so that's kind of what i'm
hoping for in the film it's sort of this
open-ended
this is our moon shot this is our moment
where where will we go next
fantastic i think this is a great
opportunity to loop in
some of some experts who are also
thinking about
these questions from different
perspectives and to get their thoughts
on the film and
their perspectives on fairness and ai so
um
please stick around and i'm gonna
introduce uh several of our other
panelists
um first up we have the wonderful sunny
kamara
hi seti sunny is a professor of computer
science
at brown university and chief science at
oroki systems
before joining brown he was a researcher
at microsoft research in redmond
his research is in cryptography and is
driven by real world problems from
privacy security and surveillance
at brown kamara co-directs the encrypted
systems lab and is affiliated with the
caps group
the data science initiative the center
for human rights
and humanitarian studies and the policy
lab
he teaches the course algorithms for the
people that surveys critiques and
aspires to address the ways in which
computer science and technology
affect marginalized communities very
impressive welcome sonny
happy to have you here next up
we have said hill mullington
sorry sinhal he is super impressive
roman family university professor of
computation and behavioral science at
the university of chicago booth school
of business
his current research uses machine
learning to understand complex problems
in human behavior
social policy and especially medicine
where computational techniques with the
potential to undercover
biomedical insights from large-scale
health data
he's won numerous awards which i'll just
mangini is the recipient of a macarthur
genius grant
and has designate he's designated a
young global leader
of the world economic forum was labeled
a top 100 global thinker
foreign policy magazine and was named
the smart list of 50
people who will change the world welcome
so much sanel
uh next up we have omar reingold he is
the rajiv matuani professor of computer
science at stanford university and the
director of the simon's collaboration on
the theory of algorithmic fairness
ryan gold has held positions at samsung
research america the weizmann institute
of science microsoft research the
institute of advanced study and att
labs his research is in the foundations
of computer science and most notably in
computational complexity cryptography
and the societal impact of computation
he is an acm fellow a simon's
investigator and among his distinctions
are the 2005 grace murray hopper award
and the 2
2009 girdle prize welcome over
and last up we have the wonderful
patricia williams who is a pioneer of
both
law and literature and critical race
theory movements in american legal
theory
and she is a university distinguished
professor of law and humanitarian
humanities of northeastern university
and a professor emirata at columbia law
school
she's also the director of law
technology and ethics initiatives in the
school of law and college of social
scientists and humanities
tons of awards of which i'll just kind
of recap a few
she is she's won a
macarthur genius award she's at the
center for advanced study and behavioral
science
and she's at the brad cliff institute
she's written
tons of publications um and her latest
book
giving a damn raised romance and gone
with the win is forthcoming from harpers
collins in june 2021
welcome patricia i'm so great
grateful to have you all here welcome
panelists okay so first i would like
to ask um so many of you on the panel
are professors
and researchers for whom the topic of
fairness has become an
area of interest could you explain how
you came to this topic and how your
background has shaped your thinking
about ethics and ai
we'll just go kind of maybe in a loop
so sandhill will start with you
that's a great question so i actually
arrived with this because
i've been working on human bias for
quite some time
and there's a lot of work documenting
large amounts of discrimination by
people against other people
and that's sort of what i had you know
been doing
the last 20 years and when we started
doing work with these algorithms it
became sort of a natural intersection of
these
but there's some tension between these
actually that i think is kind of
both interesting productive tension but
also
and that really got me and i very far
from understanding it the productive
tension being
we know one algorithm is extremely
biased whatever is inside of our heads
we know one algorithm is extremely black
box what is inside of our heads
and so when i come at it from that
perspective everything people say about
ai algorithms
it's nothing new and in fact that is
that is what we know about humans i mean
take every sentence we know you kind of
do it
and from another perspective however
um there's sort of there is something
new about these and i thought this was
excellent in your film there's the
sort of presumption of objectivity
that algorithms and data kind of put on
to things
and so for me a lot of it has been about
trying to understand how we really
reconcile
these two things and what their
differences are and what we can do with
them together
fantastic umer how about you
first thank you for inviting me to join
this wonderful panel on
this wonderful movie important movie
um so i i'm a researcher
in theoretical computer science
foundation mathematical foundations of
computer science and that's where i come
to this area i started from
from the area of cryptography and
moved naturally to privacy and then in
2010
started to look into algorithmic
discrimination
and i think the crypto side and the
theoretical computer side
bring kind of two slightly complementary
perspective that i think that i bring so
the crypto side
uh brings a lot of suspicion and
skepticism i remember 25 years ago
in a crypto conference as a student
and everybody kind of walking to dinner
expecting the nsa is
monitoring their personal discussions
but also on the technical side this
understanding this view of everything
from the perspective of an adversary
that trying to
exploit and trying to break your
definitions
and so that's kind of one side and that
side also kind of
taught me the importance of of rigor and
definitions because if you look at
something like
encryption for example you see that
you can have some definitions but then
and then you see that there is another
way to attack this definition and there
and that way you kind of progress your
understanding and get to in
more nuanced understanding of of what
you're doing and it's so much
better to argue about what definitions
make sense rather than arguing if a
system is good or bad
so that's kind of that side of the
equation the theory side i think
brings some optimism and i think it's
important to bring some
optimism to an area that's so uh
um and this brings so much pessimism
right it's so uh worrisome uh
when you look at the the impact of
algorithms and
and and how far we are from
understanding how to
to handle them in a way that would be
useful
but what we've seen in theory and
in the theory of computer science in
different areas is how
we did manage to have important impact
not to solve everything but to have
important impact in different areas like
biology and then physics and
and econ and social sciences um
and without of course trying to replace
the people that are experts in all of
these areas but
bringing the computational perspective
and we are in our first steps of trying
to do
the same within algorithm fairness and
we need a lot of optimism against this
challenge
absolutely how about you patricia
yeah i i'm a lawyer so i think some of
the first emergencies
of this problem um are when the people
depicted in this film and depicted in
virginia eubanks book
actually started to sue and so from a
very early stage i think lawyers have
been quite aware
of how this clashes with questions of
civil rights and things that are
embedded
in public law and so i view this as a
kind of clash of governance systems
on the one hand you we have at least
theoretically a model of public law
that is based on transparency
participatory democracy
input understanding of and you know
understanding of exactly what speed
of oversight basically of oversight um
and that's
kind of in intention with proprietary
models
or private law contract law um
which has a different governance system
that is to say they're governed
corporations are governed by bylaws and
so the obligation the ethical obligation
is to the bottom line
it is to uh the investors the
shareholders the
stakeholders who are not citizens um and
therefore
the human subject in a corporate and
corporate model
is at best a consumer but otherwise a
product
and that's very different from the shape
of in the configuration of citizenship
um these have different temporal models
um different vocabularies
so uh you know a corporation values
speed it values uh what was called value
added
at one point um it values uh uh
it puts great privacy on risk assessment
as as enshrining a kind of expectation
for the future
and a lot of our law is about due
process for what
happens in the present to an individual
body
rather than again the values of uh the
kind of epidemiological models that
algorithms enshrine this i think
highlights the second concern i have
which is that you're really talking
about two different discourses as well
um so on the one hand a deliberative
vocabulary is
a much more um i think that
perhaps the the contrast is captured by
what philosopher rosie
dottie has described as um she opens one
of her books with
an example of what we do every time we
encounter that capture you know you know
our prove that you are human
proves that you're not a robot um and
the test of humanity by that test
is whether you can identify a spark plug
or a bicycle or
a taxicab and that's a very
limited notion of what it means to be
human and when you think about that
much more you know its algorithms are
much more complex than that simple thing
but they don't but
there's a way in which they s that
quantitative
vocabulary in which i mean as they said
you know algorithms are about math
um a mathematical vocabulary as the
basis for this kind of human
understanding
takes out a lot of what we think of as
the human now again
law may do it as well i mean in law we
have constructions of the human
that are the juridical subject that is
homo economicus and it and you know it's
it's there there are lots of ways in
which we are also reductive
but i think a mathematical vocabulary
really does
value a kind of binarism is code
you know binary is code it um uh it is
uh it is not yet i mean certainly it's
growing in that direction
as nuanced to be able to understand the
question of irony
um it is harder i think to disaggregate
um
the individual from the collective the
epidemiological and again the
probabilistic and that's just built into
the way in which we have these
particular uh models
i don't think it's necessarily so but
that's what we're dealing with and i
think that's just
as a part of the architecture one of the
bigger problems um in
in the translation that needs to be done
between these two systemic rules of
oversight
very insightful patricia uh sunny you
were the last person on our panel we
haven't heard from yet
how about you yeah so um
yeah for me it's just always been like a
natural question right so
you know i'm a professor now but you
know more fundamentally i'm i'm
black and you know like um i was always
black so as a kid
right like bias and discrimination was
always there in health care and
education and
and you know with police brutality and
police harassment
and so what that does is that that you
know that sort of create
creates a situation where you're you're
conditioned to think about bias and
discrimination but you're also
conditioned to think about it in terms
of like systemic
problems right not just individual like
somebody doesn't like
me but also like why is this happening
to me right like
why is like the educational system where
it is why is the criminal justice system
the way it is right so this is how you
grew up and this is how you
you analyze things and so as i became a
computer scientist
it was a natural like frame of mind it
was it was an actual perspective to have
on my own field right and so initially i
was very disappointed with computer
science as a whole
because as a field i didn't think that
we
you know we we cared about
social issues and we cared about ethical
issues or anything it just wasn't part
of
our curriculum at least when i was you
know when i was a student
and i think that really that
disappointment kind of
changed into horror as i saw
how much influence computer science was
having on people's lives right there was
like a shift
you know back when i was a student you
know we thought of algorithms as things
that was running in operating systems
and you know
it would run like your your browser and
your word processor right but then there
was a there was a shift when i was
affecting people's everyday
lives and and that really that
just kind of scared me um because i
never felt like we were equipped
you know we were properly equipped to be
building
systems and algorithms of of that sort
it's fundamentally different so
all of these things kind of play their
you know played a role in me
thinking about these problems it's
such a wide-ranging array of viewpoints
through which people are kind of
arriving to a common
locus very very fascinating um
i'm wondering given your experiences so
far
with ethics and ai are there any areas
where you think that algorithms are
particularly well suited
to help with decision making and
conversely
are there any areas where you think
algorithms
shouldn't be used at all in decision
making
i we can go in any order or anyone can
jump in
um can i just say i i don't think that
that's an either or
answer i mean i actually think that part
of what we have to do the real challenge
is what david santos said algorithms
are alive he said we don't think of them
as live we think of them as neutral
disembodied uh not human and therefore
that becomes some sort of new
equivalence of fairness
i think it's exactly the opposite i
think that we can make algorithms alive
by revealing precisely who are the
programmers
who makes the decision if not the
programmers who who or what attribute
are we selling
or building into the machines and so i
think that they do need to be made alive
which is to say to reconnect
the mental constructions of the
developers to the
mathematical constructions of of of the
outcome
and without doing that um they
they they operate autonomously on their
own but you know
the language that we keep attributing to
it of
you know self-generating autonomous
autopoetic is
is does not have to be we can attach
uh that and i think one of the big walls
against
making that kind of aliveness human
aliveness
um to this disembodied world is
precisely the realm of the proprietary
that trade secrets that somehow the
the fact that these codes are completely
black boxed um is a huge problem again
it does not have to be that way but as
long as those black
box decisions are making
human decisions in the name of these
ciphers which stand in for us as
products
that then it's rendering us as products
it's rendering us as civility mortus as
we say in law
you know it's rendering us civilly dead
um because it's disenfranchising it's in
the name
of the products we seem to have become
so patricia i'll give you an example the
ai now institute for example
has called for emotion detection
algorithms to be banned
and you might agree or not agree with
that that's an area in which they
cite algorithms are inappropriately
used and maybe ought not to be used that
shouldn't be something
we can predict and so i'm just wondering
if
if that for you guys it's just a matter
of making the algorithms better and in
principle as long as we beat the human
we should be
applying them in all domains or in
principle does there exist an
area in which ai just ought not to be
used
does that clarify at all i think yeah
i think it's a very good question it is
in fact i think well posed because it's
part of what i think the way people are
trying to approach the problem right now
is there a place we can use these when
should we outside
and i i think maybe i'll take a similar
vein but patricia did which is
i think we should should be asking even
though that's the question everyone is
asking i think we should be asking a
different question
let me try and articulate what that is
so uh this showed up in the discussion
of uh daniel santos and i thought the
discussion of like you know
what makes a good teacher so if you
if you look at it for a lot of these
i think our attempts to apply ai to
these problems is actually revealing
deeper questions that are being
poorly answered and then that's where
the problem is coming
so what makes a good teacher well we've
already
in a crappy way answered that question
well before ai
we have teacher incentives we have
promotion boards that look at these
things that have already
in the past decided on bad metrics to a
degree
and those bad metrics are now being
codified into the algorithms
so if we step back and say like let's
not think of areas
like emotion detection let's actually
think of how are we taking problems that
we discuss
nebulously and transforming them
into something quantifiable whether an
algorithm is going to act on that
quantification or whether we as humans
are going to act on that quantification
what's the process by which we take
something in the world and then turn it
into something quantifiable
almost all the slips i know of happen at
that point
because the complexity in the world is
suddenly lost and is compressed
and a lot of the things happen so if i
were to describe
where i think the misapplications are i
think the misapplications arise
because we've not been reflective enough
and kicked the tires enough and said
wait
this thing good teacher
is being represented by this number do
we really think
this is a good representation of that
whether an algorithm operates
or we give out awards to teach i mean
irrespective do we and
that type of reduction happens
many many domains and in my experience a
lot of not all but
many of the problems arise from there
which at least for me helps ask the
question
okay what are the situations where
that reduction is possible what are the
situations where we think that reduction
is truly crazy and
kind of at least it doesn't fully answer
your question i know i'm side cycling
it gives me kind of a structure in which
i can look at the stuff in the world
and kind of make some sense of it
yeah um i i just want to add to that i'm
so appreciating the diversity of
backgrounds on this
um approaches to this question
um i think for me it's in that question
of
of who's the we and the question
i would sort of reframe as
not whether they're good applications of
ai and bada
and times that should be banned but i
think the larger question to me is who
gets to decide
and right now it's just um
technology companies and law enforcement
with no one that we elected giving any
kind of oversight to have what happens
and it's my feeling that someone that
represents we the people
someone that i elected and can hold
accountable should be a part of that
process
and i think what i've seen because i
don't have a computer science
background it wasn't until making this
film that i could
even had the literacy to be like that's
not
data science that's complete bogus
bologna pseudoscience
that's being sold by a private company
to make a bunch of money
and it it's very hard for people to
discern
and i think if anything um
i'm in favor of what kathy o'neill calls
for in the film which is a
an fda for algorithms some sort of body
that would vet um these systems
i who's to say maybe there is a use of
an application of facial recognition
that i would be
maybe you go before a judge and you get
a warrant for this specific usage
in this context and i think that um
right now we're living i feel like
what's happening in the industry is that
it's like um
living in an industry with like the
automobile industry before
we had car seats for your baby or
pharmaceutical products that don't have
um usage guidelines or
counter indications and so
to me it's more about the fact that we
have an entirely
um like what's described in the film is
like a wild wild west sort of an
unregulated industry
and to me the larger question is about
who gets to decide
what is the what is a fair usage and a
proper usage of these
technologies you know and i i think that
that decisional process is
also very much um uh
boggled to some degree by the by the by
the vocabulary because we
are viewing this as product testing um
in in instead of human experimentation
and
what we are doing is human
experimentation
i want to add perhaps that you know
people think
perhaps some domains are so sensitive we
shouldn't
use um algorithms
like incarceration but perhaps somewhere
else like targeted advertising
it's okay but i want to say that even
something as benign as targeted
advertising can have a huge impact
on the lives of people it affects what
kind of credit you get
what kind of jobs you you're aware of
what's your political opinions
so i can't think of any domain in which
we don't need a lot of scrutiny in the
usage of algorithms
what an array of fantastic answers cindy
i if you want to hop in or maybe i can
i can answer ask another question yeah i
mean i
know yeah i think everything everybody
said you know were
great answers i mean i think we have a
tendency especially us computer
scientists is we want to automate
everything because that's how we're
trained right so it's like
we don't even think before we automate
and and that is a
that's an issue because again there's
been a shift right
it used to be that we were automating
things that affected machines
but now we're automating things that or
those machines are affecting people
and so we need to really rethink how we
make that decision
right on what we automate and i think
our
instinct should be to not automate right
when it comes to decision making
when it comes to affecting people and
then we should ask ourselves well you
know is it okay to automate this
instead of the other way around where we
just try to automate everything and then
we ask oh well maybe
this isn't right right so um
you know i think we do need to change
how we how we go about these things and
i think
you know what patricia suggested in
terms of the vocabulary is really
important
right viewing it as human
experimentation
you know is one way to i think change
how people really
and you know especially the people who
are creating these algorithms
how they think and relate to what
they're doing so
absolutely such great great answers
um so the movie focused a lot on the
harmful
impact of technical errors and
specifications and accuracy issues as
well as on the broader normative
concerns of design and power
who gets to decide all these decision
points
in developing an ai technology or
application
application so what role do you think
scholars coming from a technical
discipline can and should play
in thinking through these various
aspects of fairness
in tech and ml
i mean so i i think you know
um i think we have a role but i think
we're ill-equipped to really be leading
the discussions and leading the creation
of the technology because again we're
not trained to do so
right like we're not our education
doesn't prepare us it doesn't equip us
to really think
deeply and broadly about you know the
impacts on on human beings and on
on societies on on you know on all of
these things and so
until we start educating computer
scientists and technologists differently
which i hope
we will i hope you know like the cs
majors and curriculums will expand
beyond stem to
social sciences and humanities as well
but until that happens
um you know i think we're really gonna
have to be dependent
on you know on folks from other fields i
think take the lead
and and give us the context and give us
the questions and give us the problems
and
evaluate whatever answers we come up
with
um you know
one of the things and this i think
relates to the point you made shawn
which i really like
which is when i think when we think
about evaluation
in the narrow machine learning sense
it's got these sort of like
type 1 errors type 2 errors it's sort of
classic statistics you use the metric
you get the expected value
but who decides
that's the metric not
not the statistical part but that's the
dimension by which we think success is
happening
like in a pre-trial algorithm to decide
who gets failed who decides what
constitutes a crime
who decides you know maybe maybe we care
about other things when we care about
impact
of the person being in jail on their
families we care about
their emotional well who decides the
dimensions
along which we are even going to do the
evaluation
and there's a second question which
involves governance which is who is
doing the evaluation and
both of these dimensions i think are
just practically if you look at the
algorithms that are out there right now
huge shortfalls on both these dimensions
like even if all the technical things
were perfectly well done
we just simply don't have any form of
independent value like
cities by it's it's an insane situation
that somebody comes to you and says
i have this thing it works how do we
know i say
so great let's do it like in no other no
other area are people so blindly naive
to think that like on your work
in you know and that's what happens with
these face detection algorithms with all
these things
so in that sense the lack of
independence and even if you move past
independence
this sort of failure to think about
who's deciding
what constitutes the dimensions on which
we should be doing the evaluating
i think that that that that resonated a
lot with me when you put it that way and
i think
that's something that we just simply
don't have a very good process
right now even anywhere that i've seen
from that
even even within companies by the way
like we talk about companies as if
they're monolithic
but you have an ad team the ad team says
well we're just going to focus on
click-through rates
but if that results in a bunch of ads
that people don't like and then that has
consequences that people leave the
platform all together
well the rest of the company would
dislike that and then of course
companies are trying to deal with that
but
you see that tension even within the
narrow profit maximizing grinding thing
which is what's the objective you know
what is the metric that we should be
using
is not a thing that we currently figured
out a reasonable way to resolve that
problem
i think that's also just a problem of
the degree to which agency in all of
this
is so disguised as long as one can say
that this is simply a mathematical
calculation
then the ethics of this as a human
enterprise or as
a propagandistic classification system
that is akin to segregation and as akin
to justice questions of public
accommodation
um then that agency is completely
irrelevant or
or invisible for me it also goes back to
just the general
uh deficits of our education system
which has increasingly placed
exclusive emphasis on stem and has cut
out arts has cut out literature has cut
out sociology and the
you know larger understandings of what
civic enterprise is about what affect
is about but what the sensorium
of responses that you know one called
empathy and sympathy and everything else
that those count
and that there are metrics for those
that are built into justice systems
that are are being excluded because
science students by and large have been
increasingly exempted
from any notion of what the humanities
actually mean
um and you know it's it's you know
simply playing with paints
as opposed to these profound senses of
um
of of what makes us act
civilly toward one another or among each
other
so i want to add a few things
one is this term technologist hide
a lot of different communities
that sometimes are viewed as one one
monolithic group
so even within computer science there
are different
disciplines with very different
objectives machine learning people are
not like system people are not like
theoretical computer science people and
those are not necessarily like the
software engineers in companies or the
ceos or perhaps
and the wall street executives that are
making are driving quite a bit of these
decisions
and are all put in this this one bucket
and i think that
it's important to understand the
different uh
roles that each one of us play
i i want to say that from so i'll kind
of focus more on my
small area which is the theoretical
computer scientists
and i want to say that i think that we
are important
not of course is replacing um
society or
policy makers or or social
scientists but we do have a role in
adding
i think important language so um
so econ gives language to talk about it
and
statistics gives language and law
and philosophy and when you're talking
about
something like algorithms
that that is a completely different
beast
you do need the language of computation
i would argue that there is no
way to have a nuanced discussion of
algorithmic fairness
without the language that we need to
develop
and we have a lot of catching up to do
but
this is an important part in it
in addition i think what we can do is
offer new options
and also understand limitations
that policy makers can then take so i'll
give an example from a different area
which is privacy
and so this new notion of differential
privacy or
ten-year-old notion
is a new option for policy makers to
take so if before the
the options in terms of data analysis
was
not around the experiment or to use
a very weak anonymization methods
or to do everything and to let
everything leak
now we have another option so um
i think that our role is to make um
the range of things that policy makers
can do
and much wider and
um and i mean i'm thinking sometimes
about
this berlin wall analogy
so yeah perhaps we needed activists and
politicians
to take the berlin wall down but
eventually
we also needed engineers to help in this
in this task and algorithmic fairness is
way more complicated than taking a wall
down
yeah truly is a multi-disciplinary
effort i definitely want to ask about
that but
before i do the notion or the
sentiment of needing in an fda for
algorithms arose in your film and has
risen a lot
in various conversations so i wanted to
ask if anybody's
thought a little bit more about what
that could look like
is there a sense in which we could
codify a set of rules or is there some
sort of elected body
that would decide on a case-by-case
basis
what would be good governance is i feel
like even the
the question of how
to govern systems and how to get more
input and share in power is
is very much murky so i would like to
get kind of your thoughts the panelists
if you have any
ideas for how that would look
i can give it a try as a non-computer
scientist but as a lawyer
yeah and one of the things that seems to
me is really difficult about this
is the sort of blind faith and omar i
absolutely agree with you that this
is complex that we need that's why i
don't want to
answer the question about you know yes
or no i mean competition of course has a
role i mean
and you know these are different
vocabularies but the
the general failure to demand
more accountability to demand more
openness
is something that deflection it seems to
me is a deferral to a kind of
totalitarianism
i view that totalitarianism is not state
totalitarianism
but a kind of monopoly uh
totalitarianism that we've allowed
certain companies to become hugely
monopolistic as was underscored in the
film
and that is a form of control that
because it's also proprietary we can't
interrogate
um and so that that that's
that's the beginning of the problem um
the other is again the siloing of
different vocabularies so that nobody's
talking to one another
and that when somebody likes me comes
and starts talking to
computer scientists they say well you
don't know anything about science and
besides it's all neutral and it's not
human
and that's the question of attributed
agency that i that that i pointed out
um i absolutely agree that there are
governance systems within that
computational world
like differential privacy um i think and
and and the question of making things
open source
so it's not just that government public
can be public
but also that these the the the
computational languages are
open and uh uh you know open source open
code
i think is a very important part taking
it out of the proprietary
secrets of trade secrets
can i can build a little bit on that i
think the fda model is kind of an
appealing
metaphor because it's out there it works
it feels like a molecule
i think for some things it could work
well
for example algorithms in medicine you
know very difficult task very whatever
for a variety of other things things
aren't
nearly so discreet and
algorithms sort of diffuse through many
different aspects
and it as sort of as a as a metaphor it
works but and i liked what you just said
partnership because in some sense let's
take
open source and making it open you know
a different analogy
could be accounting so
we have a huge set of legal
infrastructure that imposes
a ton of regulations on firms
about what they can and can't do with
accounting
what information they have to make
public and accounts are very
like secretive things but we still have
regulations that say
even if you don't make this public you
have to store all this information
that these regulators can access at any
time
so we actually have huge amounts of
documentation
and transparency regulations in place
for financial accounting and you know
finance in general
and you know of course firms would like
to do away with them but they exist and
they allow our economy to function well
i i would hope we get to that point at a
minimum
for algorithms that is that we ought to
be able to say
look if a regulator wants to go in and
say i'm worried that the pricing
algorithm used by this company is
whatever whatever
they shouldn't be able to say well that
code we don't have any it's like no
you should have been keeping all of that
give us all of your training data give
us the code
give us the code back up guess what
storage is dirt cheap
give it download to us and we'll see
what shenanigans you pulled you know if
you go to
banking for example and you want to
understand whether a bank
some of you may not know this but if you
want to know whether a bank is engaged
in discrimination
there are examiners that are sent to the
bank's offices
they pull all the physical files every
single one has been kept
they go through page by page and they
track down where there may have been
slippage
and all of that has to be kept so they
can keep every last little piece of
paper for purposes of compliance with
racial discrimination they can certainly
keep every aspect of the algorithm and
the training process that they've used
that is infinitely cheaper so at a
minimum i think
that type of i'm not saying that's all
we do but that type of regulation i
think would seem to be essential like i
don't even know why we don't
have that today
um so i i am
i view this question for galatians as
one of
the one that directs me uh most so when
i do research
on a written furnace this is one
question i kind of have in mind if
somehow somebody calls me and asked me
okay
we plan to get serious we plan to have
regulations that will really put these
companies into
uh stricter conditions what should we do
and that's kind of what i view as my
my role is to have some answer on on a
part of it not on all of it but
and and i feared at the moment i don't
have great answers yet and
i completely agree with patricia but i
mean not growing in the u.s
i always found it fascinating how much
suspicion there is towards the
government
but how little suspicion there is
towards companies
that are sometimes as powerful if if
and not more so but i'll try to give
one answer which is or two answers which
are very very
partial and and of course the answers
should come from
various different areas so they could
should come also from process
and and inclusion in the decision and
and the diversity of decision makers and
all of that
but on a technical level one thing that
i i
find that i would like to push
is um
[Music]
a moratorium on on personalization
unless it can show to uh to be
refined enough for all communities
and all sub-communities so one issue is
that algorithms
like humans are and stereotyping
and because they are trying to optimize
one thing
so in in the movie there was this uh
portrayed that
you have data and then the algorithm
just do their stuff but we also tell
them what to do with the data in order
to find an algorithm we tell them what
to optimize and usually we tell them to
optimize something global
but when you optimize something global
perhaps you don't care about some local
areas
and this is a completely complete
sub-community
so one thing i would say is that
if your personalization views
an entire sub-community as one
then this is the definition of an
algorithm that is stereotyping
so we should not allow personalization
based on data that is
and not refined enough to allow you to
discriminate
within a communities to separate
different entities with within all the
sub-communities that we care about so
this could be
an example of something we can care
about and another answer is about
labeling like we asked for foods and
perhaps
i don't know what you should do but
please tell me what do you do
the problem with that is that we kind of
think of
this five or seven companies that that
are
trading with our data but the problem is
that there are
dozens of companies that trade with our
data
and and most of them we didn't hear
about and they don't
have a reputation to lose by telling us
that oh you know
i don't care about privacy so this is
just a partial
solution so i'm even more worried about
the companies that we don't know their
names than the companies
that we do know their names and i care
i'm very worried about those too
but um yeah that's we are very very
early and i wish we
had the the industry is running because
the utility is so huge
the money is so huge and we are running
uh a little bit behind
yeah and i think it's no accident that
the united states is the site of this
free-for-all as somebody in the movie
described it but it's really a price for
all and part of it is the product
precisely
of the enormous anti-government movement
and the capitulation
from everything from citizens united
where corporations have huge
governing governance power and that
governance has been privatized
and i think that's really a problem
because we do have governance structures
and when one looks at the pervasiveness
of what not just algorithms but
all of artificial intelligence is doing
in our media we used to have a fairness
doctrine
what if we brought that back uh tim wu
one of my former colleagues at colombia
has written about net neutrality you
know we've pushed that back
we have irbs for certain kinds of
research those
irbs are not brought into this
vocabulary in terms of overseeing
the kind of human experimentation that
we are doing with poor communities as
was pointed out in this film
um medical technology black box medical
technology
makes mistakes because it's building in
formulas that go back hundreds of years
that are mistakes of
um of racialized embodiments and um
it seems to me that we have you know we
ought to bear in mind the nuremberg code
i mean we have
these ethical reference systems um
that don't become part of the vocabulary
again because it seems to me we have
um again buried the agency in
uh as as the pure scientific language of
math speaking itself into being
great great answers you know we're also
as academics
embedded in systems that incentivize
certain kinds of research
i know sunny you have
encouraged kind of us to pursue
more socially leaning research instead
of commercially leaning research
and cinderella you also have a project
which showed that
if you make social or rather if you
if you make consumer-facing decisions
like healthcare
costs a priority you can end up
discriminating and so again and again we
see
when we prioritize maybe more the
commercial
it might have these external effects
that are
unintended and so i don't know if the
rest of you have encountered this
in your experience or research but i i
if you guys could speak on that
misalignment that sometimes happens
even for us as researchers um
we'd love to hear your thoughts
i can i can dive in this can this goes
back to i think
to your the very first question you
started off remember the second question
about
what areas of application i think one
one thing and it's related to the to the
point uh
sean you made about who controls it i
think one of the biggest distortions
we see is the kinds of applications to
which this technology is being used
it's usually being used to one where
some private actor stands to have some
private gain
from the technology and in some sense
you know because that's where the data
is easy because that's who hires people
academic research tends to just sort of
follow that as well
so it's like we have a huge set of
research on
optimizing ad targeting which you know
while it's an interesting problem it's
hardly going to be thinking like so i'll
give an example
you know if you look at if you take a
a first generation college kid
we've never been to college show up at
the first day now
they're they're facing a very difficult
problem should i
take the math class that's you know the
standard one
should i take a lower level one or
should i take a higher level one
it's actually an insanely hard problem
just put yourself in that kid's shoe
it's hard because if you take one that's
too easy
actually you will have used up some
valuable time
and wasted credits are like one of the
things that and the data you see leads
people to drop out
if you take one that's too hard i mean
that's dispiriting you don't
you might be wondering do i even belong
here so
who helps me make that choice well in
practice the reality is
there's a guidance counselor you would
go to who might have five minutes for
you and
i don't know they look at it and say oh
you look mobile
but the tragedy of that is that just
even in a system like cuny or any of
these systems
there is so much data on other students
just like you who have taken
exactly the classes you did in high
school who got the grades you did
that can tell us how they did now this
problem is
very very familiar because that same kid
when they go home to sit in front of
netflix and wants to figure out
how to spend the next two hours of their
life have the world's best
best data scientists to say well you
like these movies based on that blah
what a weird misallocation that like to
decide what might dictate the future of
my life
and so that kind of misallocation of
like simply not
having talent attempting to solve those
problems and trying to
and people dictating like starting with
the student themselves like this is the
thing i need and i really have this
pressing uncertainty taking other
people's voices to decide
how the algorithm should be built but
you kind of need the technical channel
to pull the data together and
try and do stuff i think that's probably
the biggest distortion
in the entire space it's it's simply
we're not working on those type of
problems
at all and that to me is kind of tragic
yeah i mean just to sort of add on to
that i mean i think this is
um you know as you pointed out um what i
was getting at
sort of in um in my talk um last summer
and it's
it's this realization that like you know
i worked at microsoft research and then
you know i went to brown and and
i have a startup company and that's all
great right but
like all the problems that i worked on
and that all of my peers worked on are
problems that in the end will
you know have an impact on industry
which is fine like again i
i have a startup company right um but
but i don't know why
that's the case you know like why is it
that like all of us
and everything we do 100 is is focused
on that
right like in the movie there was this
community in brownsville in brooklyn
right and it's like
they also need to benefit from
technology from ai from cryptography
from all of these things
but who is actually sitting down and
looking at what technical problems
they need solved in solving those
problems right
none of my none of my colleagues are
doing that i'm not doing that well joy
is
sorry go enjoy it
you see like this is this was kind of
the issue that i had
right and that that was bugging me um
and
and you know so and the great thing
about the movie is i think it sort of
you know it underlines that right it
highlights them
well i think this is what um
what you're saying is exactly what i
meant when i said we've had this
stunning lack of imagination around
these technologies
and how they're used and i think that
has
everything to do with the economic model
that shashana zubov
refers to as surveillance capitalism and
i've often thought of it my last film
was about
[Music]
solutions to climate change and and how
solar could uplift the lives of
of working people and um
to me running an economy off of
surveillance
capitalism is as unsustainable
as running a society off of fossil fuels
it's the same kind of
extractive um
short-sighted um bad for democracy and
civilization kind of economic model
that fuels everything and to me it's
that
economic model it's not just like the
issues around inclusion
but it's that economic model of
extracting
data and the other thing is that the
fact that
you know nine companies now or
or what patricia was saying this
totalitarian
kind of have this kind of um huge power
over society when you think about
a company like google accounting for 90
of the knowledge searches globally
throughout the world i mean that is
incredible to me
and the fact that that's not actually a
knowledge platform that's an advertising
platform
and i'm i'm concerned that we won't
actually
have innovation in this field and that
we don't know
what um ai for public good
could look like partly because these
nine companies in the us
and china that lead ai have a 15 or 20
year head start
on the consolidation of our data
and then um the other thing is just this
model of the surveillance capitalism
model
in which companies basically we work for
them where they're extracting all of our
data
with no economic benefit and no rights
to us
and using that to fuel their economy and
get rich off of it and that
to me is is part of the issue
i wanted to kick in to jump in just that
uh we have i think only five minutes in
there yeah i want to do q a
sorry about that uh we do have some
questions from our audience which i want
to get to so tina
uh asked an accountability question who
is legally responsible when an algorithm
causes harm to a human for example
is it the judge who used the risk
assessment tool or the company that
released the software
how do we assign accountability
anyone want to take that on
i mean i do think that this is a real
challenge for our law
as it's presently constructed where you
don't have an agent
that can be assigned to culpability and
that's to me
the the slipperiest part of this
structure of of
um disembodying the way in which
algorithms work
um yeah i suppose one can make the judge
who
you know who relies upon an algorithm
capable in some response but that's not
really as you can feel you know where
the the the the bottom line the bottom
culpability is um and so
i think it presents huge structural
issues
when you are deciding somebody's liberty
in a parole hearing for example
based on their zip code to things like
freedom of association
it means that you are not being judged
as our entire legal system says by the
body
and the person and the behaviors in
front of you as as at least
theoretically conceived of as autonomous
but instead you're judging them by whom
uh by with whom they study
by whom they are associating um or where
they live
and that again epidemiological
perspective
is not something our law has has been
uh evolved um to deal with
and i think we have to take back that
sense of process due
and it's in the bottom line notion of
what deliberative means
which is that the efficient way of
saying well
you know you're like all of these and
therefore we can make a quick decision
decision because you're
probabilistically likely going to do
this
no no our legal system is supposed to
take
time and so one of the things that this
does
is it makes it sleek and efficient and
um you know it's it's econometrically
quantitatively um uh
right a lot of the time but to the
degree it's wrong
we don't have a well-designed cause of
action
um and so i think there's got to be a
new consumer movement a new citizen
movement
both of those together both citizen and
consumer
movement to be able to express it in
those terms
ben and rebecca have very similar
questions which is
will better engineering practices help
mitigate bias or
is it fundamentally different approach
needed and again asking about different
approaches and it seems as though the
consensus of this panel is
we do need different ways of thinking in
organizing
being around around ai
uh progress although i wanted to ask do
you
see more room for just
kind of on the algorithmic side or the
technological side for
developments and insights
as as you said many times it's a
multi-disciplinary area
and um and the way i think it has to
work is
is not like each one of us
do their own thing separately and
and we have i mean we need to do all of
that we need to develop our core areas
separately but we also need to put to
work together
and so i don't think that we can uh that
engineers can pull themselves in their
own
using their own air just
by themselves we need to do it together
and we need
also activists just as patricia said and
i think that's why the movie is so
important because
it brings awareness to something that
otherwise is just in the mind of some
researchers
absolutely absolutely um
let me add two points one is sort of
an extreme version of of saying
engineering is not going to solve it
which is if you
at least all the ones that i know that
they're sort of the documented ones
where we can actually see
the problem and the genesis of the
problem
the algorithms always did exactly what
they were programmed to do
there was no technical failure this is
not i think there's a way to think about
this that's analogous to bugs from
software engineering and we got
better at dealing with these are not
bugs the code did it exactly as it was
planned
there was no bug in the code there was a
problem in what we asked the algorithm
to do
but that's not an engineer so in that
one sense i think it's clear
engineering advances along that vector
are not going to solve this
but in another sense i think there are
some useful and important things which
is
as we enrich the question of like get
more people
to tell us what we want algorithms to do
build richer objective functions
describe those objective functions i
think that done
that then does raise interesting
technical challenges
around how do we actually solve and
build algorithms for these richer
objective functions because these richer
objective functions
can be much more complicated to deal
with for example
just to make take the most trivial point
what do you do when some populations are
represented very rarely in the data how
do you
just as a technical point if your
objective function isn't simply
do well on average but incorporate some
sort of group level things and you know
some people are just
very underrepresented how do you learn
from small data points and
so i think technical problems will
follow but i think for the problems
we're trying to solve
we actually have no technical problems
and i think it would be a mistake to
think i'll just let this
train run along and it's going to fix
itself
so i would also add like um
again i think there is a role for
engineers and
computer scientists to solve some
problems right
um but but the challenge is that
again here we're dealing with we're
dealing with people right
and decisions that are going to affect
people's lives and so like that's a
much much more subtle and more nuanced
and more important
setting than what we're used to dealing
with right because again if i drop a
piece of code or drop an algorithm in an
operating system
okay fine right this is what's gonna
happen when i
when i drop an algorithm or or you know
a decision-making
algorithm in a community right that is
going to affect individuals it's going
to affect their family
that's going to affect their communities
you know there's there's a lot of
factors around this right there's
there's going to be consequences that
are
you know that are happening because of
history right because of
because of politics and because of like
the financial situation
there's all of these things that matter
and that have to be taken into account
if you're designing systems that are
impacting
people and and that's a really really
hard thing to do and the problem is that
if we're just in our corner
you know designing our algorithms like
we normally do with our normal process
right the way we've always done it that
just doesn't translate or i mean
what's going to happen is essentially
you know we could design solutions that
we think are great but they're going to
have
huge harms right inside of the
communities when they're actually
deployed which is
what what what we're seeing so you know
so i think
in addition you know we also need
completely new ways
not only of educating computer sciences
but of working right of
of really doing our work
practicing yeah do you think the
incentives are there
do you think that's do you think that's
doable
okay i don't i mean you know we all know
or i shouldn't say we all know but you
know
i mean you know some of the panelists
have talked
you know already about the financial
incentives and and
you know eventual centers and capitalism
and how everything is set up right
so so so that's there you know my kind
of
original thought first was that oh well
you know maybe academia right can come
to the rescue because we're not supposed
to be motivated by the same things as
as industry but those of us in academia
also
kind of know and understand intuitively
that like the incentives aren't really
aligned for people to do this work right
some of us do it and some people do it
but but that's really their own
kind of like motivation right the
incentives like
aren't really set up for that so you
know so that's
that's something that we could change
and hopefully we will
because i think academia has a kind of a
golden opportunity
to do something here that is important
and impactful that industry
isn't doing and when i say academia here
i mean really computer science activity
i think
other parts of academia have been doing
this and are focused on this right so
here i'm really i mean
more like the stem fields you know i
think that's where
we've missed our opportunity to to have
an impact on the world
and to do something unique so hopefully
we'll
we'll we will do that
absolutely no one else wants to chime in
i think shafi we have
time for perhaps one more question or
two
oh i think we have more i think more
time right
i was afraid my time management was off
but i'm i'm glad you know you tell you
the clock on my computer is wrong so
it's all the machines oh okay because
you were like we have five minutes okay
well
sorry about that good good with the time
reconciliation okay
so um
i will read off another comment uh so
someone asked as tech workers we
negotiate for higher salaries and better
benefits all the time is there space for
us to learn how to negotiate stronger
ethical practices when we negotiate job
offers so i guess coming from the tech
side
is there space for agency with regards
to ethics can
what can we do what can be done i
suppose we are
a panel of academics and we don't
necessarily sit inside that
that real house but i can just say
from friends that are there that i think
that
these companies are more afraid about
losing their own
talent than they are about public
pressure so i think that it has been
shown to be very
powerful that some of these companies
it's there it's the employees that
uh drove a change i hope that there will
be more
of public pressure but i think that
employees are very very important and
they proved it in several occasions
you know going back to the previous
point made
about uh interactions or what we can do
uh i think this film was so important
because
we saw joy taking on a lot of what
academics typically don't do she
testified before congress
um and really on behalf of of other
people
and so i'm wondering do you see the role
of researchers at interacting with the
public
expanding or and whether you see the
nature of that role
changing is there potential for it to
change um
and how
anyway well i just wanted to say that um
i meet a lot of
brilliant conscientious uh people who
work inside of these tech companies
and it's my hope that they will
obey their sense of true north when they
have a moment
in one of these halls of power where
they have a moment like trenay moran has
where she's where she says
i just know something's not right here
and i think that
um i have seen a pattern with tech
companies
um of discrediting and dismissing
um independent scholars that shine a
light on bias
um that disrupts their business model um
like the firing of dr
tenet gabriel from google and um i
i think it takes both things i think it
takes people from
inside these companies and i think one
of the things i think
they do respond to is and what was
heartening about dr
um gabriel's firing was that 2500 of her
colleagues stood up
with her and did this virtual walkout
and there were resignations and that
missed and i think that um
people within these companies definitely
have a role to play
and i think that when i think about what
makes
change it is definitely people who have
the power of the scientific method i
mean i
couldn't distill this to you i relied on
people
like on this panel that have this
knowledge
and i think um just to quote uh
spider-man here um you know with great
um with great power comes great
responsibility
and i and i think you know for this
audience to understand that
in understanding artificial intelligence
you have an immense power that 90
of the population does not have and
um when i think about the fact that um
after coded bias released that
three of the biggest tech companies in
the world
changed their policy of their use of
facial recognition
to law enforcement um ibm
in an unprecedented mood disrupted their
whole
their entire business model and got out
of the game
they won't research it they won't deploy
it they're done with facial recognition
microsoft said that they would not sell
to law enforcement and
amazon took a one-year pause and to me
that sea change really uh was possible
uh in part because of brave scientists
speaking
truth to power unencumbered by corporate
interest
and we need people who have that
conviction of character to tell the
truth and to tell the public the truth
i think the other thing is um we need
massive science literacy
that is not just um science literacy and
it's my hope also that in these rooms of
power that they're also ethicists and
legal scholars
and not my mantra is like sort of don't
leave the tech bros alone
you know that's really important but i
think um
ai literacy of a massive scale is what
i'd like to see
and an investment for when you know a 10
year old is going to start using a
smartphone in the fifth grade i feel
like that's the age that we should start
teaching
about what's happening to the data and
why they get a certain ad and someone
else gets a certain ad
because i think it's that literacy that
is the foundation of us challenging
power
as a public and it's one of those issues
like climate change like the pandemic
that requires massive
um distilling of complex science to the
public and i hope that the film plays a
small role
in that and then the other thing i i
hope
will happen is as people get more
educated
that will have citizens and and people
of democracy engaged
and um like patricia has talked about i
i really see this as like the undone
work of the civil rights movement and
that
the changes that we saw there need to
happen here
from civil society sort of educating and
when i look at what happened there it
wasn't sort of enlightened policymakers
making change it was actually people
standing up and calling policymakers to
do the right thing and i
and i hope those things will happen but
i really i
i really hope that um you know the
scientists the data scientists on the
call
realize their power and act on that in
the companies that they're in
and in sharing their knowledge with with
the public
in a bigger way
i must say that of the most productive
conversations i've had about this in
my work for so many years in this field
um i'm really grateful to the simons
institute and at shafi um for
making this not just one but a whole
series of conversations
um about this issue and you know i think
there are
uh a lot of concerned people i'm
thinking of cynthia dwarf my friend
cynthia dork
who and omar you may know recall better
than i there's an organization that
she's found to call fair which
is precisely about fairness and
responsibility
in uh in in computer science and data
and
uh and you're referring to the
conference we co-founded the fork
foundation of responsible computing yes
yes yes absolutely yeah and you were our
uh
inaugural uh speaker
i just happen to be yes no not by any
accident
i mean it really i mean i i was
privileged to do that because i think
there are so few outlets
in this world that really are dealing
with
um this is an ethical problem and
providing the kind of ethical books
to um to better outcomes
um can i just add one other thing um of
course
also really concerned about how we got
to this point is precisely
michelle and he says this lack of mass
input and the little i agree buttons
that
every citizen who is sentient in the
developed world
presses all the time i agree and if you
ever print off the terms of service or
the privacy terms
they go on for 50 to 60 pages in some
instances of selling your soul
and it seems to me that part of the
reason as i said earlier it's so hard to
sue for the downstream effects
of harm or disorder or resegregation or
reordering of society
is that those contracts literally give
carte blanche to do anything
that the excavation the initiation of
what we think of as consent is being a
prime
attribute of our participation in
uh you know in in in any kind of
enterprise
um is uh you know
you read them i mean and and not only do
you
give it away in the time at the time you
sign it you agree
that the company has the ability to
change the terms of service
without your knowledge and you know they
can update it without
you know without your without your with
you as long as
and and i think that that's you know
that's a that's a granting of you know
it makes contracts illusory and it makes
their power pretty absolute
we have another legal question she might
want to take this one
algorithms used in decision making in
the criminal justice system recommend
preemptively punishing people
and the expectation that they will
commit a crime this seems
very problematic what is a legal theory
on based on which this punished type of
punishment is allowable
it's not allowable that's precisely
that's the challenge for us
um we do not punish people for things
that they might
do unless it is clearly poses an
imminent threat i mean that's the that
was the question
right that's basically what they're
asking
is somebody you know imminently about
and
reasonably um determined but but that
determination is a human determination
made by judges made
you know there were maybe warrants and
so forth involved as
felony mentioned earlier um we have due
process for determining when we are
going to stop somebody
injunctively and preemptively
preemptively empty
uh or for determining outcomes in things
like child custody
parole or hearings hiring and so forth
it it it is our metric has always been
um
individual um not assortative um
uh that that it is in the present tense
not uh not not probabilistically and
aligned to the future so that's the
other thing that's happening is that our
entire temporal disorder order our
temporal sense
of what the law does is being reordered
and naturalized in i think a very
maligned sense
so is that a type mismatch is that a
sense in which we're using algorithms
incorrectly and how will we use them
correctly in that
setting um so you're saying
they shouldn't be predictive in that
setting it should be much humans
i think it's the difference between a
doctor looking at your body and deciding
what it is that you have you know that
you have to you know you look at the
body and the
doctor diagnoses you there's a whole
separate
valid body of science called
epidemiology in which we look at you
know contagion and we look at
probabilities
for different purposes for building a
social a public health infrastructure
but we wouldn't take that public health
infrastructure and then assign it to my
body just because a lot of people
you know can be categorized by a system
that we are
then not going to um interrogate
in in its specific application and
that's precisely
i think what has come up in the covid uh
crisis
that you had algorithms built into
triage decisions and triage decisions
have historically
and i think legitimately been overseen
by do not resuscitate orders by
committees with family
and with doctors and everything was so
crowded and everything's overwhelmed but
instead you give it to an algorithm
and uh you know and and then you feed
into the algorithm that for example the
stress
of race category of race means that you
are you have a pre-existing uh
co-morbidity just
race is considered a pre-existing
co-morbidity they're going to pull that
plug a little fast
and they're going to say it's not race
it's risk and that's
that that's that's that's the harm how
do you how do you how do you
i mean that's a big problem
so we have 10 minutes left i wanted to
ask the panel if they have
any questions for shalini or if there
uh is anything else we that you guys
want to address
well i have a question for patricia
yeah let's ask questions trisha why
can't we challenge um more
of these algorithms under a violation of
due process
our due process i i think
we will begin to see that i think we are
beginning to see that
um but i think that uh you know part of
the problem
is it's just you know it's i think it's
a discourse
problem that an agency probably you know
it's the identification of the agenda uh
uh realities and uh
so as long as it's a private company and
it's a monopoly and somebody's consented
to a contract
you know it takes it out of the
conceptual realm
of constitutional guarantees of due
process
and out of the constitutional meaning of
fairness as opposed to the
quantitative definition of fairness
which is a kind of mathematical
equivalence
or you know it's almost like a you know
an equation
rather than the more complex sense of
justice
as um equity and so i think that
the the hard part of it is that we've
blinded ourselves to the complications
of this
and uh you know i think it may come to a
head in
some of the discussions of whether or
not donald trump can come back out to
facebook
and the sudden assertion of the first
amendment
um in very clear terms you know this is
a control that
absolutely goes against um right or left
you know ultra conservative or ultra you
know libertarian
this is a moment in which the the
governance of
you know our expressive freedoms is you
know we are expressing ourselves through
this uh machinery and and and i think
that that
um you know like it or not it's going to
be
in that field that even before
employment even before medicine
even for lots of you know or liberty and
due process in the in the criminal
justice system i think that that's where
we're going to have a major
constitutional test of this technology
thank you
are there any other questions anybody
else has for the director
no i have one um oh
shopping we have we have eight minutes
left so
if you want to jump in oh i was looking
at one of the questions here
um which uh
i think had to do with how to do it give
incentives for
um to help what uh daniel was talking
about
is to incentivize people let's say in
computer science to look at the
how to use technology for populations
where there's not a clear
economic benefit and i was reminded that
there was some initiative about climate
uh
trying to tell people that they when
they get a job offer
they will tell the company they got them
they offered that they would prefer to
go to the companies who
dedicate more resources toward green
energy or something of this sort
so this combines almost point that what
these companies care about is human
resources
so people are not going to take jobs so
maybe it could
make some way to incentivize companies
to
divert funds or to encourage this type
of research
in order to attract more employees i
mean i think it's a little bit of
idealistic probably
has to be very carefully thought out how
to make that an incentive
so there was one question on that that i
saw in the chat
uh and then there was i think a question
for you saying
bringing up you brought a great analogy
of a student trying to figure out which
level of math course to take
can you please explain the distortion in
that context in more details
by the way interest it was interesting
that you brought up that example because
there was a whole report about women at
mit
that they were saying that one
difference was that they were always
taking the
the beginning course so they all took
the same courses in high school
but for some reason the women wanted to
make absolutely sure that they had the
right background
but they were actually penalizing
themselves because by taking the early
courses they never got to the
chance to take the later courses i was
really advising this it wasn't an
automatic program
it was their own feelings i'm not so
sure that
a program would help one way or the
other
um anyway so that question was to you
by the distortion can you explain the
distortion
it's an instructive case i think because
the example you gave chaffey is terrific
because you've seen that in other places
where if you look at majors
in stem or in economics i've seen a few
places document this now
where if you look at a big difference
between men and women
in deciding to major it's that
men are much more likely to say oh i
gotta be in the introductory course
i'll go ahead and continue to major and
women are much less like
they feel if they didn't get an a they
shouldn't major in this thing and
that's that's a big that turned out to
have been a big divide so
i think the sense in which i think of
all of these
is that what are they they're actually
an information vacuum
you you don't know i mean if you just
think of how much of your life
you find yourself in a situation where
you just don't know most of the things
you need to know it's striking and then
you think of it
for a first generation college kid how
little they know
and the tragedy to me was that knowledge
sits in
the data really or at least some of the
things that could help bridge that
knowledge and to me i think the
distortion is
in other places we've spent a lot of
resources taking what sits in the data
and playing it back to people but here
we simply didn't
are not spending that much time in doing
that
and i think one i might almost just
challenge everyone watching i think
and i think that's what you were getting
at if you just decide i have these
tools i'm going to look for these
problems
that are socially meaningful that people
who are disadvantaged struggle with that
my tools could help
i think even just uncovering these
problems and calling them out
is already just an enormously valuable
thing just to say look
here's a recommender system problem that
doesn't look like that it looks like
here
here's a i think even just having that
and to the point of like education
picture how different even just teaching
an undergrad cs class would be
if you instead of using the usual
recommender system application
you use this one it kind of opens up
students eyes to
oh i see my tool is useful over here
i don't know if that helps i actually
had a if if we're still asking questions
to the director i had one question for
your new challenge which is
you you surely now that you've screened
it everywhere and
you're getting i'm sure audience
feedback has anything
has there been any feedback that you've
been like or any response or experience
or even like
oh that surprised me this is not
something i had anticipated going into
the making of this film or even at the
end of
this tech companies have screened the
film
and that was shocking to me because i
didn't make the film for them
and i made it for all of us to come to
the table
and um every major tech company outside
of amazon because i might have spoken
too much about amazon
has screened the film and to me that's a
little heartening because it shows there
are people inside of these companies
that want to
change the system and i hope it's the
beginning of very many films and
conversations like this one
about ethics and ai
that's interesting very very interesting
um perhaps we have time for one more
question from the audience before we end
or
should we rap i kavita had a question
uh very quickly if anyone wants to take
it although one would be inclined to
litigate for complete transparency of
algorithms are there cases where we want
to make algorithms transparent to
regulators but not
publicly available in a situation uh
they're thinking of
allows for algorithms to be public um
but
the inequities in the data can be dif
coming from different groups
and this might reinforce existing
inequities
so if anybody wants to take that last
question i mean that ought to be yeah
absolutely this is not an absolute
um i mean there are questions of
fiduciary relationship um
absolutely you need to turn us inside
out so that everything is always known
um that's you know that's already part
of the problem of privacy that we're so
concerned about but
yeah i think there's a recent case
in uh just in new jersey that now is the
land of the
it's the law of the land that um
in cases of forensics the the
the defense attorneys are going to get
to look at the
internal internals of the programs
but they're not letting them out
publicly so there's sort of a division
between whether it's
open source or whether the defense
attorney was under nda
and that's already hugely
a new case
so i want to thank everybody wow this
has been fantastic and especially
the director for making such a fantastic
film which really
makes it so obvious that we can't just
shut our eyes you know it's happening
it's out there
so many issues and dilemmas that come up
and
i've learned a lot during this panel and
definitely doing watching the movie
well thank you so much to the genius of
this panel it was such an honor to be in
conversation with all of you
thank you thank you thank you thanks
everyone